are me and peter on the same stage of
life
that's a great question pendulum says no
well now the pendulum
says yes former bachelor peter weber and
kelly flanagan confirmed
that they're dating i can say i am very
happy
the pilot and the lawyer made it
instagram official over the weekend
peter posted this picture of him and
kelly flying high writing
you caught me let the adventure begin
she's an amazing person
as for kelly she shared this photo of a
lanyard she got
from kygo the dj wrote pilot pete don't
be dumb
pick kelly i really felt something for
kelly i really did
peter already settling into his
boyfriend ways commented with i
finally got it right yes finally after
eliminating kelly before hometowns i
felt like kelly and i
we just had a really good friendship
getting down on one knee with hannah ann
will you marry me oh my god
to date madison again the way i feel for
you that's that's never
that's never changed which made his mom
barb go from zero to a hundred
all his friends all his family everyone
that knows him
knows that it's it's not you know
it's not gonna work before finally
ending up with kelly
this is truly about trying to hopefully
have an amazing love story
we know barb is more than thrilled for
her bud and kelly
barb's a huge fan she stands kelly
which i just learned which is really
funny but wait how did you learn that
because i saw her at the finale what did
she say to you she would not leave the
finale until she met me
what did you and barb say um we just had
small talk but
over to be honest the majority of it was
her hugging me
being like you're beautiful i love you i
was your fan since they won
did she say i wanted you to be with my
son she didn't specifically say that
to celebrate the news the mom made a
whole collage of the happy couple
a rose included to symbolize their
journey
she captioned the art serendipity a
mother's intuition is never wrong
e.t spoke to chris harrison last month
where he said the bachelor wasn't the
best thing for peter and kelly's romance
to thrive
the show wasn't perfect for that
relationship um i don't think kelly was
right for the show
um and she's brilliant she's beautiful
lawyer all those wonderful attributes
and peter was a great bachelor but for
them specifically
it just didn't work she fought the
concept
it was tough for her to not be in her
own head not to
try and look into the production it just
didn't work for her and that hurt their
chemistry and that's why he let her go
i think them living in the real world
and just dating
is a better environment and a better
situation so i'm hopeful i
look i'm definitely not against it and
and i i
love both of them i think kelly's great
you and i hung out with her
you know right before the quarantine we
love peter so why not